JOSH DILLON: Hi, I'm
Josh, and today going
to be talking about
TensorFlow Probability, which
is a project I've been
working on for two years now.
So what is TensorFlow
Probability?
So we are part of the
TensorFlow ecosystem.
It's a library built
using TensorFlow,
and the idea is to make it
easy to combine deep learning
with probabilistic modeling.
We are useful for statisticians
and data scientists
to whom we can provide
R-like capabilities, which
take advantage of GPU and
TPU, and to ML researchers
and practitioners so you
can build deep models, which
capture uncertainty.
So why should you care?
So a neural net that
predicts binary outcomes
is just a Bernoulli distribution
that's parameterized
by something fancy.
So suppose you have this.
You've got your
sort of V1 model.
Looks great.
Now what?
That's where TensorFlow
Probability can help you out.
Using our software, you can
encode additional information
in your problem.
You can control
prediction variance.
You can even possibly
ask tougher questions.
No longer assume that
pixels are independent,
because guess what?
They're not.
This is what we're going
to be talking about.
So the main take home
message for this talk
is TensorFlow Probability
is a bunch of low level
tools, a collection
of low level tools
which are aimed at
trying to make it easier
for you to express what you
know about your problem.
To not try to
shoehorn your problem
into a neural net
architecture, but rather
describe what you know and take
advantage of what you know.
And these sort of images over
here, we'll talk about a few
of them, but each
of them represents
a part of the TensorFlow
Probability package.
OK, so in the simplest
form, how would you
use TensorFlow Probability?
Sort of like a get our
feet wet type example.
So we offer generalized
linear models.
Think logistic regression,
linear regression.
Very boring stuff maybe, but
it's a good starting point.
So you'll see this pattern
throughout the TensorFlow
Probability software
stack and how you use it.
But basically, you
specify a model,
in this case, Bernoulli
corresponding logistic
regression.
And then you just fit it.
And in this case, we're using
L1 regularization and L2
so you can get sparse weights.
And why you should
care about this
is it's using a second order
solver under the hood, which
means that up to
floating point precision,
you would never need more
than 30 iterations of this.
And in practice, maybe three
or four is all it takes.
And since you can
take advantage of GPU,
it's like a drop-in
replacement, it
takes advantage of GPU
drop-in replacement
for, say, R in this case.
So that's just
kind of the canned,
like an example of some of
the canned stuff we offer.
Where things really
get exciting are
this sort of suite of tools.
So first we are going to
talk about distributions,
which are probably what
you think they are.
We'll also talk about
bijectors in this talk.
TensorFlow Probability
provides probabilistic layers,
things that wrap up
variational inference
with different
distributional assumptions.
We have a probabilistic
programming language, which
is the successor of Edward.
That's also part of the
TensorFlow Probability package.
And then on the
inference side-- that's
kind of for building models.
On the inference side,
we've got a collection
of Markov chain Monte
Carlo transition kernels
and tools to use them,
diagnostic criteria, that sort
of thing; tools for variational
inference in a numerically
stable way; and
various optimizers,
like stochastic gradient
monument descent, BFGS,
[INAUDIBLE],, sort of the
stuff not stochastic gradient
descent, maybe some of which are
more useful for single machine
settings, others baking in
probability with optimization.
OK, so a distribution, I hope
this is boring because nothing
here should be really fancy.
Capability of
drawing samples, you
can compute probabilities,
CDF, 1 minus the CDF,
mean, variance, all
the usual stuff.
Little more interesting
here at the bottom.
The event shape and,
you can't see it,
but it says batch shape.
So TensorFlow Probability
distributions--
to take advantage of vectorized
[INAUDIBLE] hardware,
you specify--
you call the distribution
once, but you
specify multiple parameters.
So here's an example.
We're building a normal, but
we're passing two location
parameters.
So when you call
sample on this, it's
going to return two samples
every one time you call
sample, if that makes sense.
One will correspond to
the normal distribution
parameterized with mean minus
1, the other with mean 1.
It turns out this very simple
idea is extremely powerful
and lets you immediately
take advantage
of vector computation.
So not only do
distributions have
this sort of like small
tweak from other libraries
or packages, but we've
got a bunch of them
and you can combine them
in interesting ways.
So it's not super important
what distribution this is.
The point is we're
making a mixture,
combining categorical
distributions
with multivariate normal with
a diagonal parameterization,
and it all just kind
of fits together,
and you can do cool things
using simple building blocks.
And that's a theme that's
pervasive in TensorFlow
Probability-- simple
ideas scaled up
to be a powerful
framework and formalism.
So here's another example
of a distribution we have,
Gaussian Processes.
I think this is cool
because in a few lines,
you can learn uncertainty.
So notice that
the model has sort
of different beliefs in
areas where there's no data
and it's tight where there is.
You could easily turn this
into a layer in your neural net
if you wanted to.
OK, so distributions,
there's a bunch of them.
They have these sort
of batch semantics.
They're cool.
Onto our second building
block, bijectors.
So a bijector is useful for
transforming a random variable.
It is, think like log and x.
You may on the
forward transformation
take the exponential of
some random variable,
and then to reverse it
you take the logarithm.
So the forward is useful
for computing samples
and the inverse is useful
for computing probabilities.
So a bijector is a
bijective diffeomorphism,
a differentiable isopmorphism
between two spaces.
And those spaces represent sort
of an input random variable
and an output random variable.
And because we're interested
in computing probabilities,
we have to keep track
of the Jacobian.
So just change your
variables and an integral.
And so that's what
this implements.
We also have the
notion of shape.
Because here, again,
everything supports these sort
of batch shape semantics.
So what would you
use a bijector for?
So behind the slide
is an amazing idea.
You can take a
neural net and use
it to transform any
distribution you want,
and sort of get an
arbitrarily rich distribution.
So this little
piece of code here
really is just two hidden
layers, two dense hidden layer
neural net.
And then it's wrapped up
inside this autoregressive flow
bijector, which
transforms a normal.
Now, here's why this is amazing.
You could plug this in as
your loss in the output.
Like this could be your loss
basically, the final line here.
Whoops.
I shouldn't have done that.
On the final line is just
this distribution.logprob.
That's an arbitrarily
rich distribution
capable of learning
variance, not
prescribed by like a Bernoulli.
The variance is p
times 1 minus p.
And unless your data
actually is generated
by Bernoulli
distribution, that's
a fairly restrictive assumption,
in part because anytime that's
not the case, it's very
sensitive to mis-specification.
So this is like a
much richer family.
And it sort of combines
immediately neural nets
and distributions.
So another cool thing,
you can reverse bijectors.
And this little one line
change was a whole other paper.
And we see this phenomenon in
TensorFlow probability a lot.
Because everything's low level
and modular, one little change,
brand new idea.
OK.
So that's kind of
some background.
Let's go through an example
of how you might use this.
So this is from a book,
"Bayesian Methods for Hackers,"
which we'll talk
about at the end.
And the question is, so I guess
the guy who wrote this book,
he got a girlfriend.
And at some point his text
messaging frequency changed.
So the question is, can
we find that in the data?
And maybe you'd guess 22 days.
Or maybe 40 some days.
I don't know.
Let's see.
So here's a simple model.
We'll posit that
there was a rate
of text messages
in some pre period
and a rate in some post period.
And the question is,
was there a change over?
And that's the sort of math,
or statistical program,
as I like to call it.
That statistical
program translates
into TensorFlow probability
in an almost one to one
way, exponential, uniform,
flip it over, final Poisson.
And to compute the
joint log prob,
we just add everything
up in log space.
And using that we can
sample from the posterior.
And so what we
find is, yes, there
was one rate around 18 text
messages a day I guess.
Another around 23.
And it turns out that the
highest posterior probability
was on day 44.
So how did we get
these posterior samples
from the joint log probability?
We used MCMC.
So our MCMC library has
several transition kernels.
I think one of the
more powerful ones
because it takes advantage
of automatic differentiation
is Hamiltonian Monte Carlo.
And all we do to use that
is take our joint log
problem, which you saw
in the previous slide,
and just pin whatever
you want to condition on.
So in this case, we're going
to condition on count data.
And we want to sample the tau
and the two lambdas, the rates
and the changeover point.
So we set this up.
Whoops.
We ask for some
number of results,
burn in steps, or the
usual MCMC business.
Something a little different
here is this transformer.
The transformer takes a
constrained random variable
and unconstrains it, because
HMC is taking a gradient step.
And it may step out of bounds.
And so since the lambda
terms are rates of a Poisson,
they need to be positive.
So the x bijector goes
to and from positive real
to unconstrained real.
So too with tau.
That was on the 01 interval.
And so using sigmoid,
which you can't see here,
we transformed to and from.
And day 44.
It turns out that really
was when he started dating.
And so it seems like
Bayesian inference was right.
OK.
So super hard graphical model,
which we won't talk about.
But the point is, there's
a whole lot of math here,
and it's really scary.
Not really.
Each line basically
transforms one to one.
So you pull out
some graphical model
from the literature before
neural nets got really popular
again.
And you can code it up in
TensorFlow probability.
And where things get
amazing is you can actually
parametrize these distributions
with a neural net,
thus getting the
benefit of both.
And you can differentiate
through the whole thing.
So it's really sort of what's
old is new again, yet in a way
that you can take advantage
of modern hardware.
So just one to one
between math and TFP.
OK.
So we did see a little
bit of the deep learning,
the masked R regressive flow.
And I mentioned you can
re-parametrize stuff.
So here's sort of the idea
of re-parametrization.
So, as we know, probabilistic
graphical models
tend to be computationally
very intensive.
Neural nets are really
good at embedding data
into a lower dimensional space.
Why not take your complex,
computationally intensive,
probabilistic graphical
model and parametrize it
with a neural net?
And that's kind of what
this slide is saying
we should think about doing.
So you've heard of GANs.
So variational auto
encoders are kind
of the probabilistic
analog of the GAN.
That's the adversarial
networks trying
to fight each other to come
up with a good balance.
It actually has a
probabilistic sort of analog.
And this is it.
So in this case, the posterior
distribution takes, say,
an image, and is a distribution
over a low dimensional space
Z. And the likelihood
is a distribution
that takes a low
dimensional representation
and outputs back the image.
And using variational inference,
which really just consists
of 10 lines of
code, you can take
these different
distributions, which
are themselves parametrized
by neural nets,
and just fit it with Monte
Carlo variational inference,
taking advantage of TensorFlow's
automatic differentiation.
So it all kind of
fits together nicely.
OK.
So that was a lot of information
that we kind of breezed through
quickly.
We are in the
process of rewriting
this "Bayesian
Methods for Hackers"
book using TensorFlow
probability.
It already exists.
I think there's like
a PyMC version of it.
And so we've started
all the chapters.
One and two are
in the best shape.
So definitely start with those.
In chapter one you'll find
the text message example.
But that's basically it.
So in conclusion,
TensorFlow probability
helps you combine deep learning
with probabilistic modeling
so you can encode
additional domain
knowledge about your problem.
Pip install.
Easy to use.
And you can check it out as
part of the TensorFlow ecosystem
to learn more.
Thanks.
And I've got a few minutes
here for questions,
if anyone has any.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSHUA DILLON: Yeah.
So the question is, can
I quantify uncertainty
in a neural net basically
using this stuff?
And the answer is,
absolutely yes.
That's why you would
use this stuff.
In fact, the larger question
of why would you even
use probabilistic modeling
is probably because you
want to quantify uncertainty.
And so I pulled back to this
variation autoencoder slide,
because what's happening is
it's a little hard to see here,
cause it's just code, but
this low dimensional space
is basically inducing
uncertainty as a bottleneck.
And all of your
neural nets do this.
Often you'll have a
smaller, hidden layer,
going from a larger
hidden layer,
to a smaller, back to a larger.
So the point with this is, just
do that in a principled way.
Keep track of what you lose by
sort of compressing it down.
And in so doing,
then you actually get
a measure of how much you lost.
And so while this is a
variational autoencoder,
the supervised learning
sort of alternative to this
would be variational
information bottleneck.
And the code for that is
almost exactly the same.
The only difference is
you're reconstructing a label
from some input x.
So you go from x, to z, to y.
So image, low dimensional,
back to the thing
you're trying to predict.
OK.
So I'm out of time.
And with that, I will
take it over to you.